hello my name is George Stag and I'm the
lead developer of web so today uh I want
to talk about um what I think is
particularly magical about some of the
things that webar can do but before I
start I do want to say the first piece
of magic is this wonderful logo which I
didn't design I gave doly the hex logo
for web and the description of this talk
and this is what it came up with and if
that's not magic I don't know what is
that is just
incredible so um as hopefully you picked
up from from Joe's talk web is a system
that allows you to execute our code
directly in a web browser without
supporting our
server but web can do more than this
it's not just about adding text R code
into a box and then getting text output
out of a box um web I'll let you
interact with the running R session in
in a very particular way and it allows
you to manipulate the r environment and
and reach in there and tweak things um
and it's this kind of stuff I want to
talk about today this is the kind of
thing that I find particularly
magical when I showed this for the first
time in a meeting the response I got
from the others in the meeting was just
mind blown um so I thought well there's
not there's no chance I can't share
something that good with with poscon I
have to I have
to so um the way this all works is web
assembly um the technical fancy way of
saying what it is as a portable binary
format um and it's designed so that it
can run anywhere um in particular this
is uh in browsers but it can also run
server side um and what I mean by that
for those who are interested you can run
uh Web Bar in places like the cloud and
server side um and Edge nodes and
anywhere where there's a web assembly
engine um in the future web I will be
able to run better in those than
currently um but certainly the support
is there through web assembly for those
kind of comp Computing
environments so web R is a version of
the r interpreter built for web assembly
um and that's what allows you to run
that R code as as Joe
explained so why webar why why would you
be interested in webar well in addition
to to all the shiny live stuff which is
going to be a great boond to education
there are already other tools that can
do similar things this is a quarter
extension by by James balamut uh that
can actually inject runnable code blocks
directly into a quarter output um this
is going to be amazing for or uh
educational material or even package
documentation imagine going to a website
a Pakistan website and being able to
play with a package without having to
install it I mean in certain situations
where uh the network is locked down and
that package may not even be available
to install um we saw interactive
presentations um and and as Joel
mentioned there are people currently
looking into uh running portable R
applications and reproducibility by
using shiny live um this works because
web assembly provides very strong sec
Purity features and reproducibility
features that aren't provided by a
normal uh CPU
architecture so today I'm going to show
off some web R magic I'll explain why I
think it's useful I'll explain a little
bit about how it works depending on the
time and I will be using JavaScript and
probably by the end of this there'll be
quite a few people say gosh I'm glad I
don't have to use JavaScript but don't
worry I'm not going to assume any
particular knowledge and I don't want
you to think too much about the syn TA
of the code I want you to think more
about what the code is doing to an our
environment so let's start I call this
magic trick mind reading so on the left
hand side of the screen there is an R
session and on the right hand side of
the screen is a linked JavaScript
session and right at the top in the top
left hand corner I've set a value uh in
r equal to
1729 and then in JavaScript I've run a
piece of code that's going to reach into
that R environment that's currently
running and pull out the value of that
variable
and you can see straight away that it's
returned the word promise which is not
great but it's how it works javascript's
way of dealing with asynchronous
programming is through this promises
Paradigm uh but luckily there's a
keyword so that if you put the word
await before what you want to do
JavaScript will wait for the result to
come back wait for that promise to
resolve and just give you what the
result
is what you get back is a web R object
um that looks kind of strange it's got
the sort of proxy word on it what what
you can think of that as is basically
like a black box that's linked to a
certain R object so what's happened here
is that little API call for web R has
reached in the environment and grabbed
that Fu object and returned a reference
to it and from that you can do work on
it there's a whole set of web r apis
that allows you to run methods on these
R objects and in this case the method
I've used is a method 2js and that's
taking that object and converting it
into a JavaScript object so you can see
the value of that object shown on the
screen there is 7 1729 and when you
think about it this is actually quite
quite special because if you were just
working with strings you'd have to take
that number back from the standard
output of a normal R program you'd well
it'd be even worse for if you had
something like a vector okay if you had
something like a vector you'd then have
to take your string you'd have to split
it on commas you'd have to get rid of
all the white space you'd have to pass
all the values it's a whole mmal to get
those values out of art if you're
working with putting strings in and
getting strings out but but here you
just get the numbers directly from web
assembly's memory in a format that
JavaScript understands and in a format
that JavaScript can
use the next example I'm going to call
Conjuring variables so here there's an
example where in the r session there's
an object F but it doesn't exist it's
not there the the environment is
empty uh here you can see that um we run
a piece of code that uh puts a a a
vector of JavaScript values into our's
memory and then Associates that with
with an object in that environment so i'
i' what I've done is I've created a new
object and given it a name and then when
you type the name in the object appears
it appears out of nowhere like I've
pulled it out of a hat I think this is
awesome because there's only a few
situations I can think of where that
kind of thing can happen where you can
have an object that's not there and then
all of a sudden it's there so I think
that's great but it's not the best trick
the best trick is coming up this is my
favorite thing oh well okay I little bit
um you can also do uh complex JavaScript
objects so you can see here on the right
hand side of the screen this is a nested
JavaScript object which is recursively
automatically converted into a nested R
list okay here I got excited for this so
imagine you've got an R function here
I'm just creating some random normal
normal numbers um it's scaled it doesn't
really matter what the function ises the
point is is that you can put some
arguments in and you get some numbers
back we're going to do the same trick we
did before we're going to get a
reference to that function object we're
not running the function we're grabbing
a reference to that actual function that
lives in R's memory and you can see
you've got another one of these strange
proxy objects that you can work with but
this is really cool you can invoke it
just like a normal JavaScript function
those arguments are automatically
converted into R objects and the result
is automatically converted back into
JavaScript this to me is really magical
because you don't even have to know that
that's an R function as far as you
you're concerned it's just a JavaScript
function that returns a
promise that means you can use it with
Native JavaScript Frameworks that or
just accept assuming that you're going
to give it a JavaScript function if for
something like a callback it doesn't
need to know how to work with webar you
just give it a function and it evoke
invokes
it so these examples um they're they're
relatively simple right they're but they
do demonstrate something which I think
could be a new and useful workflow when
using webar the the three examples are
are about moving data into the r
environment getting data out of the r
environment and of course running R
functions now moving data in the
environment that could be something more
complicated you could be doing a
database connection you could be doing a
user data upload of something like a CSV
you could be getting data from a rest
API these are things that the browser
can do inside
JavaScript not inside WM but you can do
it in
JavaScript running our functions I just
I just ran a a small function there that
that generates some random numbers but
imagine this could be some kind of
complex data manipulation using deer it
could be a really sophisticated modeling
Pipeline with something like tidy
models and getting that data back into
JavaScript that means you don't have to
live in the r world if you don't want to
you could take that data from webar
create a dashboard in JavaScript you
could offer it as a file download you
could even use interactive
visualizations in completely different
Frameworks such as D3 or observable and
this isn't even that that complicated um
that amount of code is enough to take
web and integrate it with observable JJs
and this this visualization here is a
web native observable plot but the data
has been taken and computed from web and
I think that is one of the best things
about webar the fact that it can
integrate so well into
pre-existing uh Frameworks that already
exist for data visualization and data
science on the
web
okay so how does this
work so the rwm process runs inside
something called a JavaScript webworker
this is important because if it didn't
do that it meant that every time you
asked R to do something your entire
browser would freeze and it's not a good
user experience to say the
least that allows the main thread to say
remain responsive um and so to make this
work communication between that main
browser thread where your website is and
where you're interacting with things and
pressing buttons s and the r process is
handled by message passing so input
messages go to R output messages come
back to you on the main
thread so if you're working with code
you could imagine you give webar the um
the command rorm and the worker thread
thinks for a bit the main thread remains
responsive and then after a while you
get some output back and you can see
here's an example of what I meant before
about the this kind of thing being
difficult to work with you can see the
output there it has a an index at the
front of it the the numbers are space
separated there's no guarantee how long
these could be they could be integers
for example so working with text is not
great and that's why web R let you work
directly with our
objects so our objects are returned to
the user as
references and handled by something
called a JavaScript proxy now JavaScript
proxies are really cool because what
they let you do is work with a certain
object but then intercept fundamental
operations so if you wanted to read a
property of that that object or if you
wanted to um say invoke the object as if
it was a function if you were doing that
and you just had a
number that would fail because a number
has no methods a number has cannot be
invoked as a function but proxies let
step in and say okay I'll let I'll do
something else instead whenever you try
and do these things so by storing a
reference to an R object and then using
the proxy to handle these things it
means that you don't need to pass around
Giant pieces of memory full of
numbers so here for example if you
evaluate some R code to generate a
vector um that that R code is evaluated
and then the result is returned back to
the user not as a vector but as a number
and that number there the the SS number
which um is it's short for S expression
it's it's a lisy thing it's old old our
stuff that pointer that number uniquely
identifies that object in our memory so
when you're working with that R object
in JavaScript JavaScript doesn't really
need to know what that is it just needs
to know this is an R object and this is
where it lives it lives over here in
memory and then when you do need the
numbers say you actually want to convert
that number into JavaScript or you want
to invoke that function only then does
webar actually go and use RC API to do
the hard work to actually get those
numbers so here you can see
only only after I actually ask web R to
convert to JavaScript only then that big
long list of numbers is returned now
here there's only there's only five
numbers but you can imagine if this was
a million million lines long or or it
had something like 10 billion points
that would make a real difference
because otherwise you'd be passing this
object around between JavaScript and R
all of the time so this is a really nice
way to deal with handling our object in
webar okay one more thing I want to to
talk about with web is service workers
so service workers is again a JavaScript
feature uh that are very similar to web
workers um but rather than acting as a
proxy on a certain object it acts as a
network proxy and what that means is
that when you ask for a website in your
browser if you have a service worker
loaded that can step in and say no I
don't want you to talk to
google.com instead you will connect to
Bing or something like that um it
doesn't even have to be another website
this this could step in stop the network
traffic compute something itself and
then return that as the
result and that's how shiny life for
python already works whenever you have a
shiny live session in your
page and a network connection is made to
what would normally be a shiny
server a service worker steps in and
redirects that traffic to to a running
pyodide process inside a web
worker and the same thing works for
R but here web R is acting as the bridge
so the service worker intercepts the
network traffic and then all those
tricks with webar all of that magic of
interacting with the environment that
can be used by the service worker to
send that traffic instead of a shiny
server into a web worker process and
because the web worker process is is
running an our web assembly loading
packages like shiny it can do that
computation and return the result
without hitting the network at all and
this is exactly how shiny life for R
works that's all I have to speak about
today so thank you very much for
listening if you do want to try out this
stuff for yourself there's some links up
on the screen there
now
thank you so much George we have time
for a few quick questions um the first
one is about
uh let me make sure I can understand
it's already so magical for me um how do
you like navigate through browser
security context restricted network
connections um in web
r one thing I need to make clear is you
cannot really work around browser
security restrictions the browsers are
written to be very secure by default and
they're constantly updated um so even if
we came up with some tricks to be able
to load content across domain or or
something like that these tricks would
they wouldn't be stable and you'd be
constantly fighting with with the
browser um I think I think that is the
bad thing to do um there are tricks you
can use um but generally the way to
think about this is that when you
interact with the the network um in a
browser on from inside a
website there is a way for the server at
the other end to tell the browser
whether you're allowed to do that um
this is called HTTP cause
headers so really we should be following
those rules and if a web server decides
yes you're allowed to talk to us they
will let you know by setting these
headers and I think that is the correct
way to think about this is how do we how
do we make these HTTP headers more
common throughout the internet so that
when it makes sense to do such
connections we are allowed to do so
thank you someone else had a question
about are there protections put in place
to prevent users from running
computationally expensive R code in web
R not by web R but browsers are very
clever um and in particular uh Safari is
very good at stopping things when they
get a little out of hand um I have on a
few occasions slipped up when
programming like all of us um and caused
a browser thread to crash um and what
Safari will do is it will just show a
little bar at the top of the screen that
says this process has crashed I've
restarted it for you which sounds great
Until you realize you've lost like an
entire shiny Live app but anyway um so
yeah browsers will normally take care of
themselves one thing that webar does not
do that I would like to do is um add uh
limits such as computational time so
that after say 10 seconds of computation
the the the process is interrupted that
would be really nice and useful
particularly for people running web R
inside node um but that's not there yet
it's on the road map
we have time for maybe one or two more
uh someone wants to know is it possible
to invoke our functions that have in
square in scare quotes side
effects I mean try it
um uh I I think so um it depends what
you mean by side effects I think I think
that person should come and talk to me
um yeah I mean it's not something I've
really tried heavily but I will say that
um the way uh that chiny live for R is
set up this this uh process of invoking
functions uh that happens directly in
shiny live we actually invoke the HTTP
UV app directly to be able to return
what that app would have returned if it
was running inside a web server um so we
do use it um but it's hard hard to say
yeah all right last question do you have
a good idea of how performance compared
between native R uh and web R Compares
uh and how it varies between certain
types of
calculations I don't it's not something
I've tested heavily um I will say that
the literature from from what I've read
the sort of the the basic idea that
people talk about when they talk about
wasm is about 80% of of native speed I
don't know how true that is it's just
what I've heard um but even the fact
that you can get to something like that
is is incredible to me considering the
security benefits that you're getting by
sandboxing your code and making sure it
can't you know destroy your file system
or the fact that you can get such
reproducible guarantees about the order
of operations of of numerical and
floating Point issues for example all of
that good stuff that you get and you're
still at over 50% of native speed to me
is incredible U but I don't have exact
numbers no thank you can we have one
more hand for George thank
[Applause]
you